c'était l'occasion les chéris de faire
le top 10 des sms qu'on ne veut plus
recevoir pour le jour de l'an c'est un
truc de fou mais quelle race frappant
déconner y'en a d'abord en numéro 1
voilà je vous le dis on commençait que
l'expert des jeux de mots c'est toc toc
toc
tu sais qui c'est le mien c'est la
pilule ap douleur mais les tables la
fiction vraie sur leur banc oui il ya
aussi le rôle ou du bureau effet on est
le 31 décembre
alors je te dit à l'année prochaine ça
se ressemble à fait aussi attention on a
les mecs aussi qu'ils souhaitent l'année
mais en deux villes est ce la base de m
quelle est la différence entre un pneu
usagé et 365 préservatifs usagés réponse
à au coude
c'est une goodyear alors ça c'est
marrant semble ya aussi les classiques
loi no joël est bon et dès 2020 j'ai eu
c'est là qu'il fait c'est vous c'est sûr
il ya aussi bad a nié pommes sautées bp
est toujours à compresser les
comprennent et imaginatif aussi ceux qui
tombent si tornados bob hope se désole
je crois que j'ai mis un peu trop de
buts dans mon champagne
ça c'est le ringard 2005 évidemment il
ya le rôle ou aussi c'est gentil mais
t'as pas envie de lui répondre tellement
le message et leur clique
je te souhaite 12 - damour 52 semaines
de richesses et 365 jours de bonne santé
willow dante comme et la gueule si le
retardataire qui tombera message passe
tout cas ce que en fait t'es sur que
derrière il va te demander un autre truc
il ya des mecs qui essaient de renouer
contact on né le 29 janvier donc on peut
tout demander de moselle ça c'est sûr ça
y est tu lui réponds il fait aux fêtes
du mois il ya aussi celui qui s'est pris
la tête mais tu aurais pas dû
ding ding ding 2020 alors oui qui reste
2021 c'est moi ces nouveaux locataires
et enfin on termine avec le mec qui veut
faire le jones les cas si milan dans sa
tête
tu envoies un texto très simple mais qui
est le plus ringard du monde
il veut dire être chez moi je m'en fous
chérie moi j'en vois un truc vraiment
simple mais efficace
allez bonne ma gueule parce que verlan
sur la bonne année et finit par ma
gueule ma gueule c'est un truc qu'on n'a
pas dit qu'on n'a pas les depuis dix ans
je vous le dis